manchmal nicht die richtigen für
thüringen ich weiß dass er hier eine
friseur kette hat und als
unternehmensberater gearbeitet das
obwohl ich glaube für die politik fehlt
eben da noch ein bisschen das rüstzeug
es ist ein politischer paukenschlag ein
ministerpräsident mit ins amt gewählt
von rechtsextremen der afd ziemlich
undenkbar schien das bis heute
willkommen zum zdf spezial die
nachfolgenden sendungen verschieben sich
um etwa zehn minuten mit den stimmen von
fdp cdu und den eigenen gerade mal fünf
abgeordneten ist der thüringische fdp
chef thomas kemmerich zum
ministerpräsidenten gewählt worden
bodo ramelow von der linken die stärkste
fraktion im landtag ist ist abgewählt
darum ging es wohl in dem erfurter polit
krimi
deshalb wählte die af.de nicht den
eigenen kandidaten sondern den der fdp
eine finte die cdu und fdp nicht
durchschaut haben oder nicht
durchschauen wollten
und das lief so bodo ramelow verfehlte
in den ersten zwei wahlgängen die
absolute mehrheit im dritten wahlgang
reicht die einfache mehrheit doch dann
ging fdp-chef kemmerich ins rennen
außerdem der von der afg aufgestellte
parteilose kandidat christoph
kindervater doch der erhielt dann keine
einzige stimme
kemmerich bekam mit 45 eine stimme mehr
als ramelow und wurde so zumindest
präsidenten gewählt gratulationen aber
auch empörte abgeordnete im landtag und
ein schock nicht nur für den ehemaligen
ministerpräsidenten sondern auch für
hunderte die heute abend vor der fdp
zentrale in berlin demonstrierten
in straßburg begrüße ich den
stellvertretenden fdp chefs wolfgang
kubicki guten abend da hat sich die fdp
gerade mal so ins parlament gezittert
und plötzlich stellt sie den
regierungschef mit gewählt von
rechtsextremen
das hat schon ein geschmäckle finden sie
nicht in der tat ist das ein geschmäckle
aber thomas kemmerich hatte lange vor
der wahl angekündigt dass er dem dritten
wahlgang nur ein hfg mann oder herr
ramelow kandidieren würde er
dokumentieren wollte dass es noch mehr
thüringischen landtag gibt rat
kandidiert hat wieder um fdp-stimmen
geworden noch kann er sie zurückweisen
es war wirklich überraschend für alle
beteiligten und die muss man gucken was
macht man daraus ja die afg hat
jedenfalls mit der abwahl ramelow
science ihrer wahlziele erreicht dank
der kandidatur von herrn kämmerin
die fdp hat also eine steilvorlage
geliefert aus naivität oder weil der
zweck die mittel heiligt
[Musik]
ich glaube das nicht weiß war auch
wahlziel der union und der fdp der
stereo abgewählt wird das ist ja auch
gelungen er hat keine mehrheit mehr im
parlament
auch kann er mehr hätten wir in der
bevölkerung und die spannende frage wird
jetzt sein
wie kann man weiterkommen es wird darauf
ankommen dass thomas kemmerich jetzt
versucht eine einigermaßen stabile
mehrheit in politische sachfragen
herbeizuführen das hätte ja auch machen
müssen mit seiner minderheitsregierung
wenn das nicht funktioniert dann wird er
das land thüringen auf neuwahlen zu
laufen ihr thüringer parteifreund
kämmerin sich jedenfalls ist so eine art
könig ohne land jedenfalls ohne mehrheit
das schauen wir uns nochmal in der
grafik anders sehen wir hier bei der
sitzverteilung im erfurter landtag die
linke ist stärkste partei
die afg zweitstärkste eine mehrheit ohne
unterstützung aus deren reihen gibt es
nicht auch nicht wenn cdu spd grüne und
fdp alle vier zusammen ging
wie soll da eine regierung funktioniere
melo hatte ja keine mehrheit
auch herr ramelow hat die keine mehr
sind wenn sie sich für viele projekte an
die mehrheiten suchen müssen ist gerade
gespräche schon zwischen linken cdu spd
bündnis 90 minuten fdp ich sehe momentan
nicht warum man die minderheitsregierung
kemmerich schlechter sein so dass eine
minderheitsregierung ramelow es wird
darauf ankommen dass die demokratischen
parteien jenseits der ard sich jetzt
zusammen finden oder feststellen es gibt
keine gemeinsamkeiten dann muss es
neuwahlen geben dann muss der wähler neu
entscheiden
nach stabilität jedenfalls sieht das
erst mal nicht aus wären da nicht
neuwahlen die saubere lösung schon beim
jetzigen stand der dinge ja so einfach
wenn wir die neuwahl ist nicht das
parlament kann sich auflösen wird zwei
drittel mehrheit die linke bleibt es
unbenommen sozialdemokraten oder grünen
eine sprechen antrag zu stellen und zu
schauen ob es mehrheiten gibt es aber
noch einmal auch die regierung ramelow
war nicht stabil auch sie hatte keine
eigene mehrheit
es ist deshalb verwunderlich dass der
ramelow den weg in den wahlgang gegangen
ist er hätte auch weitere können ohne
dass es im parlament eine mehrheit hätte
herbeiführen können also noch einmal die
tatsache dass die fdp jetzt am laster
bestellt freut mich als liberalen
selbstverständlich die politische
situation ist dadurch nicht besser und
einfacher geworden
es liegt jetzt an den handelnden
akteuren die thüringer landtag daraus
das beste zu machen noch einmal das
nicht dann wird erneut war nichts vorbei
für wolfgang kubicki vielen dank für das
gespräch
jeder kann sie was bedeutet das
thüringer beben für berlin
die ohnehin wacklige große koalition hat
ein neues problem
spd chefin saskia esken fordert bereits
eine sitzung des koalitionsausschusses
sie habe dringende fragen an die union
die cdu hatte bisher jede zusammenarbeit
mit der afg ausgeschlossen ist jetzt der
damm nach rechts gebrochen dann die
tanzend mit reaktionen aus berlin
die aussagen letztes jahr waren deutlich
sie waren unmissverständlich keine
zusammenarbeit mit den rechtsradikalen
mit den rechtspopulisten
das hat nichts mit sehr hohen cs unser
tun keine zusammenarbeit so auch markus
söder nicht mal beim kommunalen
kaffeeplausch so war dies das
meistgenutzte wort heute im politischen
berlin oft mit blick auf die cdu
schockwellen erfassen die partei aus dem
gesamten spektrum distanzierungen haben
ganz ganz viele verantwortung daran und
das geht über deutlich über
parteigrenzen hinaus aber auch die cdu
hat der große fehler nummer glaube dass
die sprachlosigkeit der union seit
monaten zu dem was in thüringen
passieren könnte auch dazu geführt hat
dass die cdu thüringen schlicht und
ergreifend alleine gelassen wurde in
einer schwierigen lage
für mich persönlich ist immer klar und
bleibt auch in zukunft klar dass wir
keine zusammenarbeit mit der afg oder
der linkspartei wollen
sonst bleiben wir unseren eigenen werten
nicht treu entscheidend ist jetzt dass
die cdu es ausschließt in eine fdp
geführte minderheitsregierung
einzutreten die von der völkischen
nationalistischen afd toleriert wird
die parteichefin in frankreich unterwegs
war ich zunächst aus der csu chef nicht
er kritisiert mit dass am ende jemand
mit fünf prozent zur minister bewähren
wird zeigt dass auf dieser ganzen aktion
kein segen wegen wird und auch die cdu
erleidet damit einen hohen maß an
glaubwürdigkeit zurück ich glaube nicht
dass thüringen jetzt mit dem heutigen
tag regierungsfähig geworden ist das
beste und ehrlichste während klare
neuwahlen ähnliche forderungen gibt es
auch in der fdp unter anderem beim
parteinachwuchs ich als freier
demokraten kann mich über diese
ministerpräsidenten wahl nicht freuen
und bin der meinung dass thomas
kemmerich nach dieser peinlichen
aktionen den weg freimachen sollte für
neuwahlen freude unterdessen bei der ofd
samt andeutung dass das ergebnis nicht
völlig ungeplant gekommen sei nun das
kam nicht überraschend
es kann jedenfalls sagt die cdu-chefin
auf nachfrage eines spd abgeordneten im
eu parlament gegen ihren willen das
verhalten der cdu in thüringen im
dritten wahlgang geschah ausdrücklich
gegen die empfehlungen und gegen die
forderungen und bitten der bundes partei
das will ich noch einmal ganz klar
stellen eine thüringische cdu die sich
an vorgaben ihrer chefin nicht gebunden
fühlt ist drohen unruhige zeiten in
erfurt und in berlin und in berlin
begrüße ich den cdu generalsekretär paul
sie merken am guten abend hier aus
berlin
in erfurt ist ja jetzt zum ersten mal
mit herrn kemmerich ein
ministerpräsident mit den stimmen der
afg gewählt worden und die cdu hat
mitgemacht warum das müssen sie
diejenigen fragen die heute ihren
stimmzettel abgegeben haben
ich habe sowohl heute als auch in der
vergangenheit ganz klar gesagt es kann
keine zusammenarbeit jedweder art mit
der kfd geben
und wenn ein ministerpräsident gewählt
wird auch mit den stimmen von nazis wie
herrn höcker und anderen aus der afg
fraktion dann ist das keine grundlage
für eine stabile regierung aber es ist
auch keine grundlage für bürgerliche
politik und deswegen darf sich auch die
cdu an einer solchen regierung nicht
beteiligen und hat es ja aber diese
zusammenarbeit cdu/fdp faktisch in
erfurt heute
gegeben hat denn für die abgeordneten
der cdu dort der zweck die mittel
heiligt ich kann nur sagen das ist heute
ein schwarzer tag für thüringen und auch
für ganz deutschland heute haben
diejenigen die so abgestimmt haben
angeführt von der fdp aber eben auch mit
stimmen der cdu mit feuer gespielt und
am ende die die politische landschaft in
brand gesetzt ihre parteichefin hat
betont die thüringer cdu habe heute
ausdrücklich gegen den willen der
bundespartei gehandelt ja wer
entscheidet eigentlich in der cdu wir
haben gerade jetzt auch mit dem
präsidium gesprochen und da war die
meinung einhellig
es kann keine zusammenarbeit geben auf
grundlage dieser war nämlich der
zustimmung auch der afd
und am ende weil es eben keine
entsprechende bürgerliche mehrheit gibt
im landtag von thüringen läuft es
zwangsläufig auf neuwahlen hinaus
das war diese gerade fragen wie geht es
jetzt weiter ein ministerpräsident ohne
mehrheit und die cdu mit im boot schwer
vorstellbar oder der fdp hat jetzt eine
große verantwortung alle die in
thüringen sind haben eine große
verantwortung natürlich ganz besonders
der heute gewählte ministerpräsident und
er sollte seinen beitrag dazu leisten
dass die menschen dann die wahl haben
so wie es jetzt ist kann es nicht
weitergehen das sage ich ganz
ausdrücklich es kann keine regierung
geben die auf die stimmen der afg
angewiesen ist es kann auch keiner
regierung geben die mit den stimmen der
afg in dieses amt gekommen ist eine
klare position jedenfalls der bundes-cdu
vielen dank für das gespräch
paul signac ich danke ihnen und im
studio begrüße ich karl rudolf korte ist
denn das was wir heute in hautnah mit
was wir heute in thüringen erlebt haben
so eine art normales demokratisches
verfahren oder doch ein gefährlicher
tabubruch mehr formal ist das alles
korrekt gelaufen aber es ist ein
bürgerlicher sündenfall die ächtung der
afc war ein kennzeichen zu einem
alleinstellungsmerkmal bürgerlicher
parteien das ist ab heute offenbar nicht
mehr der fall
und die ard ist traditionell geradezu
professionell in der regelverletzung
unterwegs mit tabubrüchen und heute auch
institutionell sie schredderten insofern
weil sie ihren eigenen kandidaten 0
stimmen gibt das hat es
bevor gegeben bei einem staunen über
dieses etwas sie haben es ja gerade
beschrieben bizarre vorgehen was wir da
heute erlebt haben sind ja aber auch die
schwierigen mehrheitsverhältnisse daran
mit schuld wie sehen sie das
ja wir besichtigen eigentlich
volkspartei ruinen die vier parteien der
bürgerlichen mitte hatten ja keine
eigene mehrheit in thüringen insofern
ist die der ausweg eine
minderheitsregierung zu bilden durchaus
eine kluge art aber ich sehe nicht mehr
eine zusammenarbeit gegeben weil der
vertrauensbruch heute doch so
fundamental ist das auch punktuelle
zusammenarbeit sicherlich nicht
funktionieren was heißt das alles fürs
regieren in berlin
sie müssen sich in berlin noch mehr
immunisieren gegen den thüringischen
sonderweg was wir in den beiträgen habe
schon erlebt haben also distanz halten
zur räson rufen so weit das geht und auf
neuwahl vermutlich setzen um sich davon
schadlos zu halten
vielen dank für das gespräch herr rudolf
korte der zweck heiligt die mittel nach
diesem motto hat die afd den sturz
harmlos und das ende von rot rot grün
inszeniert dass cdu und fdp damit
gespielt haben absichtsvoll oder nicht
ist ein tabubruch
die brandmauern gegen die afd bleiben
bestehen versichert der neue
ministerpräsident eine mehrheit aber hat
er ohne die afd
auch nicht wie daraus stabile
verhältnisse entstehen sollen ist völlig
unklar
das war unser zdf spezial vielen dank
für ihr interesse hier geht's gleich
weiter mit der krimiserie blutige
anfänger auf wiedersehen
[Musik]